hey everybody
here to talk about promises a plus and
the story behind that
um so i'm dominic um
and thanks for having me happy to be
here um
i want to start out by talking about
what i think the javascript community's
greatest strength is
and i think it's that what we do a lot
is we we turn tiny primitives
into into powerful patterns and i think
one of the most amazing examples of this
in recent times is the the es5 module
systems that we've seen
crop up things like common js modules or
amd modules
where we've taken these these hacks
really built on top of function
factory functions and objects and turned
them into a
language feature that was missing from
our language and allowed us to create
you know package managers and an amazing
ecosystem on top of that
but we see this over and over this is a
general pattern that we do
something like just modules but also you
know we have classes built on this
prototype hack and we have
callbacks that that are built you know
we pass functions to other functions and
we have streams and we have events
you know a ventimore is not part of the
language there's no like actor pattern
built in
but we're able to do this i mean
something as small as jquery's chainable
api
is an example of this that's not a
language feature that's something we've
built
um and essentially we just use these
function and object primitives to cobble
together
amazing applications and to propagate
like the wisdom of our patterns
throughout the community
and um i mean it's a bunch of hacks but
it's a bunch of practical hacks and that
really fits with the spirit of
javascript itself
you know as as its genesis in 1995 and
brendan ike's like hey let's
put this lisps semantics in some java
syntax and
cool let's go i mean that's that's how
javascript works but
i think this is also our greatest
weakness um
i think we become prideful in our
ability to shape worlds
out of the primordial stardust of
function
we get stuck in patterns we we say that
because a certain thing is
easiest to express in terms of function
it's therefore the best pattern to use
in javascript
and more generally i think that we
assume that the best ideas
are those that can be expressed most
easily in terms of javascript and most
naturally in javascript
and we often refuse to learn from other
languages and the lessons that have come
from other spaces so the promises a plus
story that i want to tell you today
is a story where we actually as a
community overcame
this weakness and i want to kind of talk
about how that went
and why it's important for the future of
really the web and the language in
general
so of course we first have to have a
minimal introduction or talk about async
programming
but you know i want to take a step back
and be more general about this than the
usual just async and javascript yeah
callbacks whatever
right the the async programming
revolution is something that's been
going on for a long time
in a lot of programming languages
javascript may have made it popular
but it's not the first place these ideas
have been you know um
it's it's popular because javascript is
popular
but but that's not that's not the
foundation of these ideas
um and and actually javascript is
actually one of the worst languages for
async programming
um and i think the reason for this is
largely historical
um you know javascript's initial
asynchronous apis came from this this
wonderful
set of apis called the dom and we all
know how pleasant
dom apis are to work with but that's
that's where they came from
so um you know essentially all
javascript asynchronous apis
end up being in this thing called
continuation passing style
i mean here's a node.js example because
node.js kind of tried to clean up the
dom's legacy but they really
they just latched on to that train where
you want to do something asynchronous
you pass a function to another function
and you stuff
all of the rest of your code in there we
call this continuation passing style you
pass a continuation of your program
to somewhere else um i mean node decided
on a common signature for its callbacks
kind of getting away from the dom's mess
of you know sometimes we'll use events
sometimes we'll use callbacks sometimes
we'll just do whatever um
and and but it and then you know most of
the time it's consistent
but it never took a step back and said
what's the landscape of design patterns
for asynchronous programming how could
we kind of
look at what other languages are doing
or what other frameworks are doing or
what's possible
when you want to do asynchronous
programming it just stuck with what the
dom was doing
which is just continuation passing style
and i think this is generally part of
the trap that we often fall into the
the more functions trap i like to call
it and you spell it m-o-a-r
um and where you do literally the the
simplest thing possible
so continuation passing style in my
opinion is easy
right everyone can do it callbacks are
easy but it is not
simple so easy in this sense i mean it's
like the nearest thing you reach for
it's it's a very familiar tool you reach
out and functions are there and you pass
functions to other
functions and you need to do an async
operation you just stuff the rest of
your code in a function
everyone can do this like if you can't
do this you're kind of a javascript noob
and and like people will make fun of you
but they kind of should because this is
a very javascript thing to do
like i'm not kidding um
but the thing about continuation passing
style is it is not
simple okay it is not what do i mean by
that exactly like what
what's the difference here that i'm
trying to get at well
i think the way that i've kind of come
to think about this over the top over
the years is that continuation passing
style
traps you in something called the turing
tar pit and this is one of my favorite
conceptual
entities it's the idea that you know
because you have a turing complete
language
you can just cobble together whatever
program you want
you you rebuild whatever you need and
this is often seen in the dom or in
you know in the browser where you're
like oh i have javascript i'm just going
to redo all of the browser's primitives
in terms of javascript
like that's you're getting trapped in
the trying tar pit but it's the same
thing
you're in you're in asynchronous
programming in javascript land and
you're like oh well
i have javascript i have a term complete
language let me just cobble together an
asynchronous abstraction like using
the basic javascript stuff and the
problem is that
as with all touring carpet things you
end up reinventing basic features of the
language
something like returning a value or
throwing an error
or a call stack you lose those and you
try and reinvent them by cobbling
together these
crazy combinator functions that just tie
together other functions to try and
express
your basic ideas and and of course it's
not hard
right everyone can do this this is easy
stuff but it's not
simple at all and this kind of
complexity that comes out
really has the kind of maintenance and
cognitive burdens
that you would expect from a complex
system you know you're always making
asking questions or you know
second-guessing yourself you're saying
did somebody accidentally call my
callback twice
or you know did they call it with both
an error and a value or what's the value
of that thing i use to do things in
parallel it's like a counter sometimes
but sometimes it's a map but
i don't know like did i remember to pass
up the errors to my caller like
the answer to all these questions should
always be i don't know and i don't want
to know i don't care i just want to do
an asynchronous function call
and i don't care how like that would be
something that was simple
but continuation passing style and
callbacks in general are not simple
so the way that other languages have
solved this asynchronous function call
paradigm
if you want to look to them for for
lessons is
by a concept called promises and it
comes from some very old languages
jewel and e are kind of the originators
of these and these are somewhat academic
languages
that haven't seen that much practical
application but they're really
interesting
and they have some first class support
for this kind of asynchronous function
call idea
but it's made its way into a lot more
mainstream languages as you can see
you know it's in java it's in python
it's an f sharp and v f sharp got into
the dot net in general it's in simples
plus now it's
of course it's in dart because dart have
everything it's and it's it's in
javascript
um in the form of promises a plus
and so i think it's interesting seeing
this list because generally when you see
a list like this where all these
languages have adopted this feature
it generally means either one of two
things it means that the idea is so good
that everyone had to copy it or it means
that there's some convergent evolution
on a solution that everyone agreed was a
really good one and promises i think
are a bit of both so
you know to convince you of this i don't
really want to show you how to use
promises in javascript i think there's
there's a lot of good blog posts on that
it's it's fun it's i'd love to you know
do a little tutorial
but i think i want to kind of blow you
out of the water here and say
why you should use promises in
javascript with some really compelling
examples
so the essential point of promises that
i want to show with these examples
is to give you bat is that you're going
to get back asynchronous versions of
return and throw
so instead of thrashing wildly in this
touring tarpon
only to sink further into this callback
molasses we're going to turn our
attention to
an abstraction that can bring us back
into the semantics of javascript the
language
the one that we're used to we're going
to create an asynchronous call stack
with these promises
regaining all the semantics of the
language as just like with synchronous
return and throw and we're going to
integrate well with synchronous return
of wealth throw
and so i think for this reason promises
are fundamentally a simple thing
they allow us to compose our stuff in
the same way that a normal language
construct would
and you can compose asynchronous
function calls with promises
without having to entangle your concern
of calling the asynchronous function
with the function's concern of calling
your callback
and so i think the first really drastic
demonstration of this
is available to you actually if you go
to chrome canary and turn on some
experimental javascript flags so let me
show you about something called
generators
so this is this is actually not promises
related at the moment
um but so the idea here is you declare
this special type of function called
generator function
which gets a little star next to its
name not a typo
and in the middle of these you can put
statements like yield
so in this example this function yields
up a few numbers and in between the
yielding it
logs some console statements a b c d and
so i
when you call the function it doesn't
actually execute any code right away but
instead it gives you this iterator
object
and then when you call next on that
iterator object it'll execute the code
it'll log a
and yield you this one and what that
translates to is this object
value one done false because there's
still more code to run
but the rest of the code doesn't run yet
so this is starting to look really
interesting this is something we have
don't have in javascript the ability to
pause execution of a function
um and it's still completely single
threaded and there's no like blocking
thread stuff going on here but we've
paused execution and said well
let's just not execute the rest of code
and so you know you keep calling next
you keep executing more pieces of the
code
all the way down until you get to the
end when after you've yielded three and
got value three done false
you call next again and you get d value
undefined
done true so this is pretty magic and i
think what's really fun is that if you
go to this js bin link
and turn on your chrome canary flags you
can actually see this in action
you can write this code and it works and
so that's that's pretty amazing
and i'm really excited about the next
version of javascript in general but i
think this is really powerful
because this idea where we pause
function execution go off and do
something else and then come back
is exactly what we need to implement
something like
asynchronous code that integrates well
with our language and with promises
because they're an abstraction for
asynchronous functions that integrate
well with our language
we can do exactly that so using the
queue library
and this is also code that works today
in this js bin
you can do something where you do an
asynchronous function call to this get
repo events function i wrote
which is also written with promises and
generators
and you call this you use the yield
keyword to suspend execution
until it's ready to come back and then
it goes and updates the ui and so on
and i'm also using yield down there to
delay for 500 5000 milliseconds
and what's amazing here and what you
don't see in a lot of these solutions
is we integrate well with the
surrounding language constructs and in
this case i'm using try catch finally
this is not something you can see and
you no longer have to do these crazy
like combinators to say oh
well sometimes there's an error let me
handle that well but in both cases i
want to execute the finally function but
if that exit
throws an error then i do want to
propagate that and so on
you get all that for free because
promises as a solution
integrate well with the language and
they they can be directly dropped into a
generator solution
for the when the language evolves that
and so
yeah that's pretty awesome um
all right so the other major thing about
promises that i think is really cool and
kind of gives you an idea of their power
is that as a bonus to just this fitting
well with a language abstraction
we get time travel as i like to call it
because promises
are objects that represent another
object that will eventually be available
it's an object from another time um and
so
you you can get a really fun like
example of this with this this
unit testing assertion i've put down at
the bottom and i have a library that
does exactly this it's called chai as
promised
where you can say like i eventually
expect this object
to deep equal these things so if you've
ever done asynchronous unit testing it's
i mean it's easy but it's not simple as
as you
as i emphasize like it's just it's a
pain it's not as simple as it should be
um but you know let's let's actually
step back a second and let justin
timberlake tell us what's cool
because uh time travel isn't cool
uh really i mean i don't know what well
i kind of disagree with him but
but he thinks that space travels uh much
cooler
so uh so let's look at this example so
this goes a bit beyond basic promise
stuff which is usually just then
but the idea is you have something like
a promise for a user
i mean you call this get method and to
get a property
called repos and that actually gives you
a promise for the property called repos
and you keep chaining off of that you
say oh we're going to get the promise
for the property zero of the repos
get a promise for the property commit
history of the zeroth repo
and then i'm gonna invoke this function
so i'm gonna promise for the results of
the
invocation of the two html function on
that commission history
and then i'm gonna display it in the ui
and then i'm to get it done and i do
want to point out that in ecmascript 6
with the proxies feature
this is going to look really pretty just
like all our backbone code where we do
get set blah blah blah blah all our
ember code and so on is going to look a
lot prettier
but it's not just like okay here's some
nice syntactic sugar for some common
promise operations like getting
properties and invoking methods
um what if i told you that the user
promise was actually a promise for a
remote object
an object on another computer right so
everything here takes on a new meaning
right what's happening is not just that
we're saying oh cue up these actions to
be taken in the future
we're saying cue up these actions to
happen on another computer
and then the computer will say oh well
he called then let me send back what
i've currently computed
the the html rendered on the server so
if you're twitter and you don't believe
in rendering things on this client
this might be a good way to go um
so i think this is really neat because
we've we've got an abstraction that was
originally meant for kind of
asynchronous programming but essentially
it can be used for distributed
programming so we really know we're on
to something kind of fundamental here
all right um and you can actually do
this today
uh we're using a library by chris kowal
who's sitting right there
called q connection and in this case the
remote sources
can be a web socket a web worker or a
message port which is a way of
communicating among
iframes usually and so you can get a
promise
using today's like using libraries today
for a remote
user object and then you can queue
messages to send across these boundaries
to remote computers or remote iframes or
whatever
and so this is i think a really neat
demonstration of promises that goes
beyond
the normal stuff so that's kind of the
end of the
promises are really cool part of the
talk and now i want to talk about
something that i think
is is really impactful for
kind of how how javascript as a
community and a language evolves
um the pro the story i promised you
earlier where we overcame our greatest
weakness of the desire to build
everything and reach for the easiest
thing
and and so on and so the story of
promises a plus
um it it it all started with this thing
called common js promises a
and actually if you look at this message
it's it's by a guy on the the common js
mailing list
proposing to base it off of dojo so it
actually all started with dojo which as
we learned
two days ago it started everything
but but the idea of promises a and dojo
promises before them
just captured the core idea of promises
from all those other languages we saw
the idea of an asynchronous computation
in an object
but it had some problems as as a
community created spec it was
underspecified it was it was missing
some key features that all
implementations actually ended up
implementing
um it was written in some some
paragraphs of pros that were really easy
to misinterpret
and one of the unfortunate consequences
of this easy to misinterpret nature of
the spec
was as i like to call it
moneybags.deferred
so moneybags.deferred you know this is a
this is a
screenshot of a issue tracker while i'm
arguing with its maintainer kind of
saying hey it would be really cool if
you guys adopted the promises a standard
instead of this misinterpretation of it
you have
and the response is like sorry it was 3
am when i was reading that spec and i
got it wrong and now we're stuck with it
so
too late um and so they they had a
really bad reading comprehension
issue there like they missed the whole
async sync parallel
and so these these deferreds as like
whatever
like they they don't match promises
conceptually at all they don't integrate
well with the language they don't do the
async return throw thing at all
so they failed reading comprehension and
i think the only realistic response to
that is a
godzilla facepalm so whatever
i'll do my own thing i'd recently been
added to this
q library by chris kowal um but i saw
a solemn vow on the the grave of the
dead callbacks that i buried
that i'm not going to let this happen
again
so um when you know some sometime later
this this library you may have heard of
called ember got a pull request
um that said add ember.deferredmix in
which implements the promises a spec
i took a look at the code and i found
out that actually those are horrible
horrible lies
um and and you know we've seen like like
this
this misinterpretation of promises a had
gone on
again you know and then it's really a
systematic problem and so
you know the the first appropriate
response to that is of course a double
bunny face bomb
um but um after i was done
done with that i got really angry um and
i wrote
wrote this uh this rant called you're
missing the point of promises
and this this kind of had surprisingly
large circulation um which was cool
so people were listening to what i wrote
and people really seem to understand it
like the idea that oh wow
these libraries are missing the point of
promises they're just using it for like
callback aggregation
they're not trying to integrate wobble
the language and provide a sane
asynchronous primitive for a
value that represents a asynchronous
computation
um and at the bottom of the gist i
wanted to end on a positive productive
note not just like i'm ranting on the
internet i said i would produce a test
suite and once you put something on the
internet with a promise you really have
to do it otherwise people will hate you
forever so
i did i produced a promises a test suite
which people started using which i
thought was really cool and at this
point actually yehuda katz
one of the main people behind ember js
got in touch with me and he said yes we
totally want promises a compliant
promises in ember we don't want to make
that jquery mistake
and he created this library called
rsvp.js which is one of the more popular
promise libraries today
and i think this this was really kind of
the start of something great
so here's a here's a screenshot of that
test suite that i created and
i mean it's it's i'm very happy with
with how many people
started conforming to that but then the
real magic happened
so so what happened next is this guy
called brian cavaliere
who should be in the audience but i
haven't seen him there he is
um yeah he uh he created this gist or
guest a
gift or something
where uh called promises a plus um
which you know is a brilliant name i
wish i thought of it where uh
you know we're going to take promises a
and we're going to clarify it we're
going to say how
let's put this in in like real language
not a few paragraphs let's put this in
like speckish
type bullet points and kind of say what
exactly are the requirements
that have emerged over the last few
years of promised implementation in
javascript what do we need
to create an interoperable set of
promise implementations
uh man and from that that little gist um
we ended up with this
beautiful github pages website um you
can tell that i'm a designer
um and uh no really it's like it's
it's a pretty nice you know spec that we
created and it's got its own domain name
now promises a plus dot com
um and this time we actually made a test
suite unlike the poor promises a guys
if if only they'd known how important
that was um
and then jquery well um
okay but so what so we created this this
spec and we put it up on the internet
and has its own domain name
um but it turns out that when you write
a clear and thoughtful
specification for something that people
like to do like
people have been doing for a while like
promises and you create a nice test
suite for it that's very thorough
then people get really excited about
implementing that so you end up with
we've ended up with over 30
implementations
of promises a plus spec and we've
actually ended up ones with actionscript
python and objective c
which i think is pretty amazing and
what's great about this
is is not that like yes we've forced
everyone to conform because we really
made sure to
do only specify the core piece of the
promise implementation that's important
the then method
and every implementation now has a good
then method which means you can build
libraries that work with any
implementation
you don't have to choose one and say oh
everybody has to use my promises a plus
implementation if they want to benefit
from my library so this is pretty
awesome and
actually there's there's another
implementation of these that ended up in
the dom
spec under the wonderful name dom
futures
not sure what that's about but uh dom
futures are kind of like dom promises
and uh that no but seriously we have
promises in the dom now
and there's been major work throughout
the the what wg
um and the w3c to encourage the use of
these these dom promises these dom
futures
in upcoming apis i mean it's actually
gotten kind of ridiculous the amount of
times the mailing this posts get
responded to with
oh you should use futures like there's
some uh
if you don't have an api that's using
futures you might as well just set some
up just in case
this is from an amazing site called
w3cmemes.com
so that's that um but even more cool
than that i think
even more cool than getting our promises
a plus spec into the dom
is for es7 this is a presentation that
was recently given at a tc 39 meaning
there's a slide saying we're going to
try and get these kind of cool
concurrency things in there
and as part of that we're going to try
and create a promise implementation
standardize it in ecmascript 7 in the
language
based on promises a plus so so what just
happened
somehow promises a plus this little
thing we put up on github became the
starting point for any conversation
about promises in javascript how did we
end up like supplanting promises a
so dramatically and and why am i getting
weekly queries about whether jquery will
fix their broken promises like that wow
jquery they have so many users but
people want them to conform to my spec
like you know how did we go from some
nerd rage over a pull request to ember
to to something that's influencing the
dom and even ecmascript seven
like how did how did a bunch of
implementers congregating on github and
doing our own thing
suddenly end up influencing the what
what in the w3c and tc39 like this is
amazing
so to end my talk i want to kind of
point to some principles of this thing
calling open specification development
so so it's it's the answer to the
question what made this promises a plus
effort work so well
and be so influential i think it boils
down to a few principles
of this this idea so going through them
in turn
like our cause of bringing sane
asynchronous programming to javascript
is is this is the stuff we talked about
earlier like this is important
you know this is this is kind of
something people can get behind you
can't build a specification like this
around things nobody cares about you
need to solve real problems
and you need to solve them with coherent
solutions you need to have something
that people
really can get behind and have been
using and need to solve in the real
world
the next thing the people right we have
a really strong and cooperative
community
working on promises a plus um it's led
by brian who really did a great job
you know hurting all of us sheep into
into the github repo to talk to each
other
on a good ground and we all care deeply
about these issues and we all were
willing to make sacrifices and
and change our our own implementations
to conform to something that would be a
core
set of behaviors we could all agree on
um
the code so so this is a probably the
biggest reason
and and this is all about what i was
saying at the beginning how we harnessed
the javascript developer's
you know desire to create everything
from function and object you know we'd
already done this
we had implementations like when and q
and rsvp was starting to get some buzz
where we'd implemented promises in
javascript itself
and we did this before we banded
together
so so the idea that we have these
existing implementations that already
explored the problem space
and decided oh well this is kind of
where we're converging it all ends up
looking kind of like this let's just get
all the edge cases narrowed down and
create something we can agree on um and
in short like this is
code before pros right get get your code
made
get a get a prolly fill as they call it
like a
this is what the web api of the future
probably should look like
um out there before you write down a
spec and say everybody should follow
this
um the contract right so the contract of
promises a plus
is a very small thing we only specify
the core then method
because that's enough that's enough to
get interoperable promises that everyone
can use
we could have been fighting over who's
api to standardize no i want the queue
api i know i want the when api
we didn't even specify how do you create
a promise we just specified once you
have one
how does it have to behave and this is
why i like to say that the dom future is
a promises a plus promise implementation
even though it is excel for spec because
just like qrwen
it's building on this core interoperable
then method that can work with other
than methods and other libraries
to create a larger surface area that its
consumers can use and as consumers are
in this case browsers
finally and this can't be underestimated
the setting of github
plays a large part in in our success
right github
is where we as a community work and play
you know it encourages like easy forking
pull requests reviews
ever it has markdown which you know
markdown diffs are really easy to read
so if you come into a repo and you want
to see it
see what's been going on with the
specification you can actually tell
what's going on
if you look at some of the the history
for the w3c apis
it's this mass of html and you have no
idea what's going on
um but everybody like just that's part
of like everybody knows how to interface
with github in this community we all
know how to look through old issues how
to
send a pull request how to look at diffs
like this is where
we congregate and this is where how we
should be working
um and even the w3c and the what would
are starting to get in on this
they're starting to see this they put
some of their specs on github but they
haven't really made the transition
because they still cling to these
archaic old mailing lists where with
these archives that are
impossible to navigate and it's you
can't really jump into the middle of
conversation very
easily and it's very frustrating trying
to get involved in the standards process
when you have to subscribe to these
things that bombard your inbox
in this like you know 1990s way
so i think github is a is a big part of
why we were able to collaborate so well
so to close i want to take a look at our
our slogan
for our tagline for promises a plus you
know we spent a lot of time getting this
right actually and
it's it's a bit bit silly sometimes but
in the end i think it's perfect we end
up meaning every word
the promise is a plus organization and
the standard we're open
we do everything on github it's out in
the open we're sound
that's our cause we want sane
asynchronously in javascript
we're interoperable that's the the core
contract we're providing for everyone
and we're by implementers and for
implementers reflecting our commitment
to build on existing code and to
leverage the strength of the community
we already had
so if you have all these open
specification development ingredients
in place then i think you're in a place
to extend the web forward
and this is referring to a concept that
started becoming popular recently
it's a specific philosophy championed by
the newly reformed
w3c technical architecture group in
particular by yehuda katz
brian alex russell and brian cardell
who and the essential idea is that when
we build things on the web platform
it shouldn't be magic browser apis that
go into cpus plus
and do crazy things and we don't have
any idea how to interface with
it should be core primitives in
javascript that then build on each other
and allow us to create the next version
and so then
we have this virtuous cycle just like in
promises a plus
where the community says oh i have these
tools i'm going to build a new api on
top of them
and then the community can compete
between themselves and refine and
converge around something
and eventually a common primitive gets
established and we can take that back
into the web platform itself
all right thanks
you